hey welcome to the monitor as always I
am Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired
this week we have for you a return to my
roots and in particular the roots of my
sense of humor if I can be said to have
one perhaps not you make that call we
have a new triple album that is actually
three old regular albums we'll talk
about that but first we have a tiny
little indie video game I like to give
shine to these kind of smaller
enterprises this one is called call of
duty black ops 2 maybe you've not heard
of it in which case I welcome you back
to civilization this is trey arcs newest
installment in Activision's multi
quintillion dollar grossing first-person
shooter franchise and what's nice about
call duty black ops 2 is that treyarch
which is really known for what they did
in the original black ops which was kind
of overhaul the multiplayer component
which as we know is why anyone plays
call of duty but they've read rejiggered
it all over again so there's this new
thing in call of duty black ops 2
multiplayer called pick 10 in which you
basically have ten slots to fill instead
of the conventional call of duty
character loadout in which you give
yourself two weapons that each might
have an attachment and the perk and this
and that you have ten slots you feel
them however you want if you want one
weapon that's completely tricked out and
you just want to rampage with that go
for it but it also means you're going to
have to sacrifice other things that you
won't be able to do as well as other
players who might have taken that option
do you get what I'm saying it's kind of
this Solomonic Sophie's Choice
multiplayer thing and another thing
that's nice about black ops 2 is kind of
traditionally Call of Duty is one of the
only franchises that doesn't really have
a place for people who want to play
support roles if you want to heal people
if you want to hang out near and
objective and just help defend it
there's finally a place for players like
that in black ops 2 you don't have to go
full Chuck Norris you don't have to hide
out in the trees with a sniper rifle and
go Apocalypse Now on people you can just
kind of you you can know your role a
little bit and rack up points regardless
there's a place for everyone that is it
that is black ops 2callofduty colon
black ops 2 if you want to be official
about it it's out this week let's talk
about music
hey are you doing as you can make it
special guest now over the course of
last year there's a singer-songwriter
out of Toronto named the weekend that is
the weekend without the third e so wek
ND it looks kind of like a tech startup
like Flickr or Grindr I don't know why
pick those two at any rate last year the
weekend put out three free mixtapes that
were all fully fledged albums in their
own right there was house of balloons
then there was Thursday and then there
was echoes of silence then he signed
with republic which is a small imprint
label and the speculation was was he
going to put out an all new album and he
might but first what happened is this
week republic released trilogy which is
essentially those three mixtapes packs
together into a single triple album
which if you picked up his mixtapes last
year and you were familiar with them no
of course you don't need to get it but
if you've been hearing the song wicked
games on the radio and wondering who
this guy is it is the weekend that song
has actually been out for like a year
and a half but based on this new kind of
retail release that single is just
picking up steam now he's also got this
unbelievable scorcher cover of Dirty
Diana by Michael Jackson that's called
DD that you that you need to hear anyway
all three of those are fantastic albums
which means that the album trilogy is a
fantastic album so I beseech you to pick
that up if you are unfamiliar if you are
not unfamiliar just wait for whatever
he's doing next and of course he will be
doing something again and it'll be great
but until then this week you've got
trilogy back to you okay thank you now
for me growing up Mad Magazine was maybe
the biggest influence on the way I saw
the world I have a stack of back issues
a couple feet high in my childhood
bedroom and what a Time Inc used to be
Time Warner used to be Warner who owned
Mad Magazine what they've started doing
recently is publishing a series of
retrospective kind of hardback
collections they've done it with writers
recently one about a mad artist more
Drucker came out and now there is oh is
it levitates from my lap totally mad 60
years of humor satire stupidity and
stupidity now
mad as it is now you may not read I
don't fault you for not reading that but
if you go back you might be surprised
you might be surprised because you still
don't think it's funny but for anyone
who grew up reading mad magazine trust
me when I say that this brings you down
memory lane in only the best way from
classics like dorky dancing the satire
of dirty dancing to later satires like
and this is this is classic mad satire
nomenclature star black deep space swine
it's so hacky and delightful that my
producer who was off-camera right now
and also loves Mad Magazine is
convulsing with barely restrained
laughter because she knows how much she
loves it too totally mad it came out
last week it is in fine book stores now
and probably not so fine book stores but
that is it for the monitor for the week
on behalf of Alfred and also on behalf
of me I want to thank you for watching
yet again and being a part of our
monitor family you can always email us
at the monitor at wire calm if you have
any suggestions or questions or what is
this Mad Magazine and why did you spend
so much time talking about it why do you
find this funny it's ridiculous anything
along those lines but until next week
when we come back at you with more pop
culture freshness inspirational
catchphrase here
you